[Music]
welcome everyone to the session my name
is Misha Brookman I'm the product
manager for Google cloud BigTable and
with us today we have the unstained from
ebay who will talk about how Abe a
brings together billions of product
listings to enable new shopping
experiences using Google Cloud BigTable
Leon hi so first if you a few facts
about eBay eBay is a truly global
company we have 167 million buyers in
over 200 countries all over the world
over 57% of our business is
international and we are pretty big on
mobile right with close to half of
business coming from mobile and 348
million mobile app downloads other
brands of eBay include eBay classifieds
and stop hop so at the heart of what
debate does is eBay catalog and eBay
catalog is pretty big and in this very
rich and very complex so we have well
over billion listings available
worldwide in eBay catalog at any given
moment and over 15 million listings are
added to the catalog every day and
catalog is comprised of many different
data sets coming from many different
data sources so if you look at an eBay
listing you will see obvious things like
title price variants description
attributes images right but there are
also many data elements that are not
visible and they are computed behind the
scenes by many different algorithms to
enhance selling and buying experience so
it's not unusual
for anybody listening to take megabytes
not counting images and of course the
volume of updates of eBay catalog is of
various datasets in eBay catalog is very
high and we will talk more about that so
with our team which is new product
development team and we build
applications on Google cloud platform
first thing we wanted to bring over is
the catalog and we needed a scalable
platform but to to effectively enable
new shopping experiences globally right
showcasing you Bay inventory we want the
platform that allows us to scale on
demand with data volume and traffic we
wanted to be able to iterate quickly and
integrate with data heavy AI
technologies our first application that
we launched this last October is AB a
shop bot so you can go if you have if
you happen to have a mobile device or
laptop you can go to Shabbat ebay.com
and start playing with it so you base
Shabbat is in you is a newer smarter in
easier way to shop in chatbot context
right and it leverages AI with Nou
dialogue management and also and also
visual search so you can snap a picture
of an item you're interested in and
submitted to the Shabbat or until
hopefully find something very close so
as a number of challenges of course with
bringing all the data over to Google
cloud platform first the catalog had to
be brought from many different sources
and we wanted to bring it in a way that
is really convenient to work with so
that instead of having different pieces
of catalog in different systems we
wanted to have all data affect
effectively together so it's much easier
to work with it in different contexts
and enable different shopping use cases
with it so we also needed to provide a
highly scalable in a seasonally fast way
of accessing catalog data right we have
hundreds of thousands of updates per
second on catalog data right with
hundreds of megabytes written and very
high volume reads for example an update
to catalog results in search index
update and in order to reindex a listing
in real time you need to know more
information about the listings an
happened with just that update so we
have more reads in terms of volumes and
than right so our reads are in many
gigabytes per second and of course we
wanted very low latency replicating
catalog data from ebay core system to
Google a platform so that it is
important in retails I mean to have
up-to-date data so if listing is no
longer available we don't want to show
it if price change if price changes we
want to show updated price and we needed
we also needed very high consistency of
the data so so that we in case even if
an update is missed in near-real-time we
still want to make sure that we have a
mechanism that repairs this data so the
data replicated data is eventually
correct inconsistent with what we have
in core right so for example if price
changes and we were least in good bot
and we didn't catch this event we want
to have a mechanism in place that
ensures that we will have data
eventually correct
in Google platform so about Google cloud
platform you know it is there are many
great features and I just want to
highlight a few of them that that that
we really leverage it is first it is
global presence which an eBay as a
global company needs a platform that
allows that supports global presence
really well also comprehensive and
highly coherent technology stack and we
are cutting edge where we like to work
with newest technologies and and GCP
provides those newest technologies right
for us and it has leading support to for
Cuban artists with container agent and
we leverage kubernetes in many of our
services so it was very important to us
and finally there are some unique
offerings in DCPS there are many of them
but for this talk I want to focus on
BigTable that was the data storage that
we've selected for the catalog and we
will go in more detail on how we use
BigTable with that ok so this is a
high-level diagram that just covers our
data ingestion pipeline it doesn't cover
our whole infrastructure on GCP it's
much bigger but this is just the part
that is responsible for getting the
catalog from eBay core systems to GCP
and in the next slides we'll go in more
detail in parts of it and with that I'll
pass it back to Misha for a deeper dive
in GCP and the systems
talk about Google cloud platform in more
detail I thought it would be worthwhile
to look at the history of Google and
where Google comes from and how we
arrived to the point that we are today
Google originally set out to organize
the world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful and
for that Google build web search now
that is a very specific application
there's a lot of various search specific
algorithms and details that go on behind
the scenes but even with this very
specific application Google had to solve
a number of very generic standard Big
Data problems to be able to enable the
search application service for one we
have to be able to store a large amount
of data and depending on the type and
the content of the data we need to use a
different storage system for those
different types of data so we need to
use file systems databases and other
types of storage systems once we have
that data we need to be able to process
it at scale and we needed to both be
able to process that data in batch mode
to analyze the link structure of the
world wide web as well as to update data
in real time as web pages change so we
needed a real time streaming pipeline as
well and then to be able to serve the
data we needed to be able to deploy and
update our services and we use a micro
service architecture we need to update
them quickly and without any downtime
Google built a number of generic
infrastructure components and with that
it enabled a number of teams across many
different domains within Google to build
a number of services that each of which
serve over a billion users so each of
the services that you see featured on
the slide from Google itself Google com
to Google Play Chrome Android YouTube
Maps Gmail and Google cloud platform
each of those serve over a billion users
and the way that we've been able to do
that is by using similar architecture
and infrastructure components across all
of them so all of these services benefit
from the same hardware infrastructure
networking the global network that we
have built to enable them to operate at
the scale that they do not only the
hardware but all
so the software over the years Google's
built a number of software components to
enable all those projects to scale
starting with file systems such as GFS
on to processing systems such as
MapReduce flume and mill-wheel
to analytic systems like dremel
databases like spanner and BigTable and
container managers like Borg Google has
been able to build these generic systems
such that each of those teams were able
to innovate and build the
domain-specific components that they
needed for their services without having
to reinvent and resolve the standard Big
Data problems that they would all face
consistently and now with all these
technologies that Google has built over
the years to support all of its own
products we're making all of them
available on Google cloud platform in
the various areas of compute storage
databases big data processing and
machine learning so that anyone can use
these building blocks to build their own
applications and their own services and
have them seamlessly scale to serve
millions and billions of users let's
talk about a couple of these components
in more depth so for one as I mentioned
we needed to be able to run systems and
we needed to be update upgrade these
systems very quickly and efficiently
with no downtime Google started off by
building container support by writing
the C group support that we open sourced
and contributed to Linux over a decade
ago but we also needed to be able to run
these container as workloads so we built
Borg and then we open sourced a
container manager called kubernetes and
now we've created a managed service
offering that uses kubernetes and this
is Google it a container engine
container engine provides cluster
management and orchestration for your
containerized workloads it also provides
a private container registry for you to
deploy your applications the
applications can use a declarative
specification for resources that
kubernetes and container engine will
enforce and it also provides auto
scaling to meet the needs of growing
applications we also needed to have a
file system that would scale to the
growing needs of the Internet and so we
started off was we built Google file
system and then we've upgraded that with
Colossus and today we offer that as a
service as Google Cloud Storage Google
Cloud Storage is
an exabyte scale storage system it
provides high throughput it provides
replicated storage across regional and
multi-regional modes it also provides
several different types of classes for
your data depending on whether your data
is hot or cold or somewhere in between
and it uses the same API so you don't
have to change your code depending on
which type of data you're accessing it
also provides an HDFS compatible
connector for coop so you don't have to
change your code if you're using could
do with HDFS it were seamlessly with
Google Cloud Storage again across all
those different storage classes and
different bucket types once we have the
data we need to be able to process it at
scale and we're talking about both
static and streaming data Google's
written several different systems from
batch to streaming such as MapReduce
flume and mill-wheel and then we
combined all of those together to offer
as a single product Google Cloud
dataflow then we're going to step
further and we've open sourced the SDK
behind Google Cloud dataflow as Apache
beam Apache beam recently became a
top-level project in the Apache Software
Foundation dataflow combines both batch
and streaming modes so you don't have to
change your code from one to the other
you can write your code once and you can
run the same code in both batch and
streaming modes dataflow provides auto
scaling and dynamic tasks charting so
that you're not affected by long
stragglers doubling or tripling the
total length of your job as dataflow
notice is that some of the workers are
struggling to process the data it will
dynamically split those data and then
Auto scale and provide more workers to
handle those shards that are taking
longer than others dataflow provides
connectors to our various storage
systems such as bigquery BigTable and
cloud storage so you can read and write
data from anywhere and as I mentioned
code that uses the open source Apache VM
SDK also becomes portable you can run
Apache beam workloads on data flow as
well as spark and flink we also wanted
to be able to run open source processing
engines such as Hadoop and spark
directly so for that we built Google
Cloud Data proc data park allows you to
run Hadoop
spark Pig hive and other open source big
data systems it also provides connectors
to BigTable big
and Google Cloud storage so again you
can read and write from anywhere and
because it can read and write data from
anywhere you don't have to write in
stateful clusters instead you can run
stateless clusters that have their
storage external to them which means you
can very quickly and easily spin up
clusters run the jobs that you need and
send them down data Park also provides a
higher level jobs API such that you can
just submit jobs rather than thinking
about container clusters long-running
clusters managing those clusters we also
needed to have a petabyte scale database
when we used to build our search indexes
in batch mode in bulk it took a long
time to keep rebuilding the entire
search index it also made the index girl
stale over time because we would not be
able to catch the really quickly
changing web pages as they changed in
real-time so what we needed was a real
time low latency access to the data sets
scaled into the petabytes and for that
we wrote BigTable and we're now offering
BigTable as Google Cloud BigTable as a
fully managed service on Google cloud
platform big tables are fully managed no
sequel database as I mentioned it
provides petabyte scale data state data
scale storage with low latency access
for both reason writes it provides very
seamless scalability for throughput and
it learns and adjust to access patterns
let's look into a more detail about
those last two points and how we provide
that so first let's talk about the
structure and the schema for BigTable
BigTable is a mil sequel sparse white
column database so what that means is
that BigTable has a single key which is
the row key it does not do joins and it
only does single row transactions it's
sparse so that means whenever you don't
store the data in any one of the cells
it does not count against the storage it
is white column which means that you can
create column families and within each
column family you can create essentially
an unlimited number of columns so you
can store any number of data items key
to a single row as you need the way to
think about BigTable as a data model is
as a three dimensional spreadsheet there
are rows there are columns and each one
of the cell has an arbitrary number of
versions which are keyed within
before bit integer you can treat that
64-bit integer is time and that is a
very common use case but you can also
treat that as just an arbitrary version
and just assign them versions as one two
and three BigTable is an underpinning
aidid storage system so you can store
any type of data its uninterpreted so
they're just bytes and there are many
different applications that can be built
on top of BigTable however for each one
of those you would have to design custom
Roky schemas for a number of standard
use cases there are open source systems
that already predefined those schemas
such that you can implement these common
use cases very easily so BigTable has
native support for time series because
it has that third dimension of time but
you will still have to carefully design
your time series schema to make sure
that it performs well or you can use one
of the open source systems such as
heroic by Spotify or Open TS DB which is
an open source time series database in
fact Spotify runs their monitoring
system today on BigTable
using the heroic system alternatively if
you need to run graph workloads of
course you can implement a graph schema
using something like adjacency lists
using the white column database you can
also use one of these to graph
abstraction systems such as H graph DB
or Janis graph to provide you with a
standard tinker pop API implementation
on top of BigTable Janis graph is
something that we just launched recently
in cooperation with several other
companies IBM Hortonworks X peril and
grokken this is a new project as of two
months ago in the Linux Foundation that
is now working with BigTable it also
supports other open source wycombe
databases let's talk about the big table
implementation and the architecture
behind it so this is a somewhat
simplified architecture and we're going
to go into depth in the next few slides
clients connect to a load balancing
proxy endpoint which then connect to the
processing nodes of BigTable note server
nodes in the next few slides I'm going
to remove the load balancing proxy layer
for clarity to show whether the record
the requests are actually routed but
just remember that there's a single end
point so there's no need for a discovery
service for each client to know where to
connect to all the clients connect to a
single end point one interesting thing
about BigTable is that as a database
BigTable itself is actually stateless
BigTable does not store any data and
this is actually true for all the other
big Google storage systems BigTable
spanner bigquery and Google Cloud
Storage all use the Colossus filesystem
so BigTable nodes provide you with
access and they mediate the requests
between the clients and the data but the
BigTable nose themselves don't store any
data now this provides a couple of
interesting features as to how a big
table operates let's say we are looking
at an access pattern such as the one in
the in a diagram where the big table no
one on the Left is getting more requests
than the other nodes and that is because
it is managing the data in Colossus the
regions a B and C and that data appears
to be popular with the clients as
BigTable notice that one of the nodes is
getting more activity than others you
can easily reassign the ownership of the
data to a different node and the
requests will be rerouted automatically
again remember there's that load
balancing proxy layer this is possible
to do quickly because we're not actually
moving any other data none of the nodes
actually store the data within their own
containers so this is just a metadata
reassignment which happens very quickly
we don't need to copy terabytes or
petabytes of data to be able to do this
reassignment so this happens very
quickly in fact this happens all the
time so for example if you wanted to
scale the cluster the same thing happens
it's very easy and seamless the scale
clusters because again we're only moving
the reassignment now remember that each
node has to have exclusive access to the
data that it's managing because we're
providing atomic single row transactions
this means that you can easily scale the
clusters up but this also means that you
can easily scale the clusters down so if
you know that you need to do some
workloads that will change in the size
and type and nature of the workload you
can easily send an API request resize
the cluster up
do your additional processing with data
proc or data flow or any other system
and then scale it down and pick tip will
handle the management automatically one
interesting thing that also happens is
with BigTable the throughput scales
linearly in proportion to the number of
nodes for one because it's very easy to
scale the clusters and because the nodes
themselves don't talk to each other
they're completely independent the
throughput scales in proportion to the
number of nodes in many other storage
systems this performance would typically
flatten out after a while but with
BigTable it scales linearly so whether
you have three thirty three hundred or
more nodes the throughput and and
processing will scale linearly last year
we did a test with one of our customers
with 3,500 BigTable nodes and 232 VMs
and again the throughput there scales
linearly at this point I'll pass it back
to Leon to talk about the architecture
that you saw earlier in more depth
Thanks so going back to our bay use case
in our challenges so we had to
synchronize the catalog over to Google
cloud platform in an areal time with low
latency and talking about single seconds
of latency and with high consistency so
we also want to serve the catalog data
to other services that consume it on the
Google cloud platform always high
read volumes and low latency right and
we also want to support the vision use
case right so we want to keep listing
images in Google cloud platform for
training vision models and also we want
to keep a eye vision signatures which
are pretty much feature vectors over
images somewhere so that we can extract
and build image search index out of them
so we've selected BigTable
to store catalog data which might may
sound unusual it's not like Misha
mentioned you know a big table is an
opinionated data store so it worked
really well for us it is highly scalable
and reliable so solution and with amount
of data and volume of updates and reads
right
it was the store that could handle this
it has excellent performance and another
important consideration for us at the
API the Java API to BigTable is actually
based on HBase client so if you don't
know about HBase Apache HBase is open
source no sequel databases that was
modeled after Google published BigTable
paper so HBase was modeled after
BigTable and you know the ideas kind of
that Apache BigTable utilizes are the
ones that were introduced by a big table
and it's very nice that Google chose to
to implement Java client as fully
compatible HBase client so you can write
code against BigTable as you would write
it against HBase so compared to each
base and another very popular no sequel
database Cassandra the performance of
BigTable is significantly higher so in
addition you know it is fully managed of
course on Google cloud platform
so while Cassandra and HBase deployments
are non-trivial to support and
especially at big at large scale it is
well integrated with DCP console and
rest of the Google cloud platform stack
is mission mentioned they are connectors
from data proc data flow so and going
back to perform
you know this chart shows a benchmark
that actually Google made a couple of
years ago comparing BigTable performance
to HBase and Cassandra and you can see
that the writes and reads is where
BigTable consistently takes 6
milliseconds preparation and each Basin
and Cassandra are in hundreds of
milliseconds well Cassandra does better
on obviously on writes because that was
that's what it was optimized for so
another great features of well big
tables is seamless cluster resizing so
we run pretty large BigTable instance on
hundreds of nodes but sometimes we need
to make bulk loads that you know require
much more resources and you know and we
can add hundreds of few hundred nodes to
our BigTable instance and in 20 minutes
you know it is all pre balanced and
ready to go and we can you know and we
can send logged to BigTable and then
after we are done we can remove this
nodes and it just continues going you
know we don't see any degradation in
performance the imbalance is happening
it's works really quick really great
also the administrative operations
against BigTable like adding new tables
changing column families they're all
non-blocking and they can be done on
running BigTable instance and again
there there is no effect on running
applications finally a lot of magic I
guess was you know as we as we were as
we been working with BigTable for the
last year we realized a lot of magic
with performance goes into the client
and Google is actively working on on
open source BigTable client and and we
were really happy with all
optimizations that we've seen that went
into the client over the past year and
we are sure it will continue going this
way so back to back to the diagram so
this is the diagram at at high level you
can see that we use many different
components on GCP platform just to
support catalog congestion so let's
focus on our near real-time
synchronization pipeline so in ebay core
on the left you see we have our private
cloud where we have compute storage and
streaming right that where data is
originally hosted so we have exposed all
the updates that go to different data
sets that comprise eBay catalog we have
exposed them as kafka streams so there
are dozens of different data sets that
compose eBay listings which are
partitioned across many kafka streams so
we are dealing with close to 500
individual streams and these streams are
consumed by strom topologies that we
manage and run on eBay side if you know
we probably could have considered a
patchy beam for that but we have strom
topologies that consumes this events it
aggregates them in micro batches does
duplication and then sends the smart as
its micro batches over to GCP we use
Google cloud load balancer right at
France Cuban eros cluster of our catalog
service that that receives this micro
batches and micro batches may contain
anywhere from one to a few hundred
records right and then insert them into
BigTable
so now let's look at the table that
where we stores our data so we chose to
store the data in the original format
that we get from core and the reason for
that is we want to be really flexible in
how we expose this data so the most
flexibility for us would be not to make
any changes to raw data but rather have
a separate table where we you know
convert and transform the data
so having data in the original format in
DCP gives us ability to go to go to go
back in the computer target model at any
point of time the datasets that we get
from Cora are included in Apache Avro
format so every cell here actually
contains a record with multiple fields
that are encoded in our we have a
separate table where we store a ver
schema so we don't lose track of those
and you can see that we have multiple
column families so in fact for every
data set we use we have a separate
column family and that gives us and that
helps us as a like isolating the the
load on BigTable right because the nice
thing about : families is that if you
have independent reads right so if you
read from is alright to a particular
column family you know it doesn't feel
as a column families right so you can
have many of them you can have hundreds
of column families but but you only even
need to write so reads only once that
you touch mother so in every column
family we have two columns one for
metadata that that captures information
on where's the record originated from
some correlation ad fires you know we
sound the streams that we consume come
from Oracle GoldenGate so it will
capture Oracle raw
IDs transaction commit sequences and
whatnot and then the average that
contains the data itself right so you
will also notice that we have and RT ZZ
: family's prefix with an RT which
stands for near real-time and DW so we
will cover it later and in for some
datasets these are duplicated so the DW
are coming from batch and I'll explain
later why we do that now going to roll
key design right
as I mentioned listing listings are
comprised on many different kinds of
Records and you can look at it as
hierarchical parent-child data structure
so if you have a listing one two three
it may have variants right one and two
so we prefix write the key by the
listing ID then we put : qualifier for
the kind of child we are writing and
then after ensign : and then 0 85 for
the that child and then if you have
grandchildren you know we'll keep
appending to the key now so that allows
us to keep all the records belonging to
the same listing together which is
really important with BigTable because
they can be scanned together really
efficiently so so BigTable allows
scanning by key prefix and this records
are physically stored together so you
can read them really quickly now with
key design it is really important to
avoid hot spotting which which is having
keys that are monotonically increasing
or decreasing so with eBay listings we
do not have exactly that but the
distribution of keys in of listing
identifiers in eBay is not exactly
uniform so we chose to reverse
lexicographical is the listing ideas
and that makes a distribution uniform
and avoids any potential interference
with how the data is distributed in
BigTable and how it is scanned and you
will also notice that you know there's
this great these gray cells contain no
data and which is fine because BigTable
doesn't punish you for having sparse
data sets with right so so you don't pay
you don't write when you if data is not
there it doesn't take space so as no
sequel database the BigTable supports
retrieval by keys so if you have a key
you can get the value or you can scan a
key range these are basically two
fundamental access buttons with BigTable
so you cannot have secondary indices
supplied by BigTable itself but you can
make one for yourself as another table
in BigTable and we use that since we
need to know we were accumulated over
the over a year or so that we've been
running on Google platform we've
accumulated billions of listings and
hundreds of terabytes of data in
BigTable however it is really important
for us to know which listings are
available right now which is about 1.1
billion and we want to scan the listings
that are available right now really
quickly for example if you want to
rebuild search index from scratch or to
run some reporting so for that we
maintain a separate table which is
really small or really narrow that only
contains the identifiers of the
available listings so if listing becomes
unavailable we just delete delete a
record from BigTable or if we get a new
listing that is available we just add a
record here and the 980 fires the
listing and key fires are prefixed here
by site IDs inside ID stands for
for market were listing will where item
was listed United States
you know UK and so on this allows us to
scan just for available listings in
United States or just for available
listings for UK so we can rebuild the
index just for the subset of markets
that we want to and then we have a few
columns you know in this case we put we
add seller ID and leave categories ID if
in case if you want to do additional
filtering as we scan this data without
having to do lookups against row
listings table now the value of so as I
as I mentioned the worries that we want
to bring to the stack of applications
that use catalog is by representing eBay
catalog in a coherent convenient way to
other applications so we've developed
schema for or data structures that
represents a big catalog which is much
more convenient than the raw data that
we get so we store the data in a
separate table and we choose protobuf
lotta buffers to represent the schema is
that schema and we also break it up into
sip in into into fragments that we store
across : families so that we can
retrieve them separately for efficiency
so in case if you only need to know
about variants you can just scan that
column family right we also we use here
each record contains a single listing ID
each record contain a single listing so
the keys are lexicographically reversed
listing IDs and we also have this source
version column that we use for lazy
rebuilding catalog model so
usually very very build catalog model as
we ingest new data but in some cases you
know when we do batch operations we can
just increment the version right within
this table without rebuilding the whole
model so next time we need to read we
know that the model that we have in this
table is stale and we need to rebuild it
so next the catalog service so catalog
service is running or as I mentioned on
Cuban Edison container engine and it we
so we've chosen to front all access to
BigTable right by this service so that
clients that need to deal with catalog
data they have to go through catalog
service they don't have to deal with
intricacies of BigTable storage so and
this service you can imagine it's it
runs on peach a large number of
instances because it gets a lot of read
and write heats from all over and
container engine really helps us with
managing deployments then scaling of
catalog service we have it fully
integrated and continuous delivery
pipeline that we run on core and we
write our images to contain registry in
Google cloud platform and do rollout in
managed way so it doesn't impact the
capacity of our service so it's been
working really really well so this
service is processing many thousands of
batches per second right with everybody
hundreds of Records so it's pretty heavy
volume service
now I've mentioned that we needed a
mechanism to ensure that we don't miss
updates right we in case if we our
near-real-time pipeline is designed not
to miss updates so if for some reason we
cannot write to BigTable we'll just go
into this infinite retry loop and then
you know and then alert and then and
then someone has to come in and fix the
pipeline right so that updates keep
flowing but you know it happens at
upstream we might miss an event just
because something happened at upstream
from us so for that and also to support
datasets that are not in that are not
available in near-real-time we varied a
batch five line so batch pipeline
synchronizes some of the main data sets
about eBay catalog that contain price
and availability information so and we
do it daily so in case if you missed
price for reliability update at the end
of the day we will catch it with a batch
update and we can silent and so this
inconsistency will live in our catalog
for up to a day we also have a dashboard
for highly visible items we can compare
what is in core systems to what is in in
BigTable and then force synchronization
now the way batch pipeline works first
we have of course budget data is
extracted from our Hadoop and Tara daily
their data warehouses that run in core
and then this extracts that we run daily
are broken into many small fragments
containing you know up to a few million
of Records and we lose this batches over
to Google platform and we put them in
Google Cloud storage and after each
fragment is transferred we invoke a call
to catalog service so that it can load
it from Google Cloud storage and stream
it from Google storage and steam and
stream there's a batch
into a big table the seperation is that
important so if something breaks we can
repeat until we succeed and we keep
track of all the fragments both on core
in a simple sequel database so we can
account for each fragment so we don't so
we make sure that everything is loaded
completely and we also keep track of
this batch operations in one big table
side so that our our load operations is
effectively non-blocking so we just make
a call to load and then we pull against
the HTTP API of catalog service to check
whether the fragment is loaded which may
take from few seconds to couple of
minutes so next part is integration with
with search so search is really the main
consumer of catalog data for us so it
has two green index listings in real
time as listing information changes in
retail world you have to index in real
time we've chosen to put pub/sub between
our search index build and our catalog
service just to give a little room for
our index build process to to adjust to
spikes in the in the number of updates
so so if there is a big spike pops up
we'll buffer it so and search can work
at its own pace Search Indexing can work
at its own pace so the way it works we
the the way it works as data is pushed
to catalog service the identifiers of
the listings that are affected along
with some metadata that tells which data
set this update is coming from and
actually in a bitmap containing the
indices of columns that got touched
but that update is put on pub/sub so
each message may contain a number of
listings corresponding to the MicroBot
along with the metadata
search consumes search index build
consumes this messages from pub subtopic
and based on what changed about listings
it decides what it needs to fetch from
catalogue service it usually needs to
fetch more than just the data sets are
changed because you know indexing
involves with pretty complex operations
that requires no knowing a lot about the
listing but but in certain cases it can
just take it it just needs to know a
subset of listing darian really helps us
with reducing the load against catalog
service and BigTable so that is pretty
much how our nee real-time search
indexing works so next as I mentioned
our shop bot our shop bot supports image
search image search you snap a picture
you or use an existing picture you give
it a shot bot and it finds items that
are available that look similarly it
works really well it is easy image
search that we have the image models are
developed in-house in fact we've just
submitted couple weeks ago submit the
paper to kdd 2017 where we describe in
detail how we build our image models and
how our pipelines and image serving and
image search walks to detail so if you
are interested please ping me offline I
can give you more information about that
so our catalog servers and big table
were ultimately participate in the
process of helping enable image search
so what happens is as we get catalog
data as we get catalog data we detect if
images if you have new images or images
your list of images for a listing
changed so in response we download these
images from eBay a core we save the
images in
in GCSE and Google Cloud storage and we
also have a GPU cluster where we around
our own vision models where we pass the
images to compute feature vectors right
I represent exist images and storing
these feature vectors which are you know
half a megabyte ha 5 512 bytes right
half a kilobyte records right to
BigTable so here's how our images table
looks like so it has image unique
identifiers a key and it has it has it
stores a couple of versions of image
signatures the reason we saw a couple of
versions
it helps us transitioning from one music
music model to another so in case right
it helps with smoothly transitioning of
that finally we have another small table
that just keeps image hashes over the
bits of images and that helps us
deduplicating the images in our business
we find that quite a lot about 20% of
images are actually duplicates and they
submitted under different names so this
helps us identify if an image if we
already seen an image in the past in
that case we don't save it in Google
Cloud storage it helps us with managing
reducing our Google search requirements
finally we do batch processing games
BigTable so this batch processing we
have several use cases for batch
processing right one of them is building
image index and for that we need to scan
all available listings and we use that
available listings table that I
mentioned that we have and then for this
listings we retrieve all the image
signatures and write them to GCS Google
Cloud Storage and that partitioned by
certain grain with by category and then
it gets distributed to a cluster that
serves image searches so we use both
cloud data proc and cloud dataflow of to
scan big tables it is great support for
that so just a few best practices and
tricks about BigTable so first pre join
your data alright if you have many data
sets that share the same key it's best
to put them in the same table and then
you can leverage and then you can you
can use you can scan and accesses data
together right you can also leverage
atomicity that transaction support at
roll level that big table has and then :
families allows allow you to separate
the load with different access patterns
and then they and then with key design
right first you need to design a key to
avoid hot spotting and we covered that
and there are several methods of doing
that you can use hash of the key you can
use you can choose one of the columns in
the data set as a Pathak's or like we
did you can try reversing your key
lexicographically and that may improve
your key distribution and also key key
prefixes Allah help with optimizing
queries right if you want to like we do
when we want to scan listings for
specific markets and also you can use
key keeper affixes to to represent
parent-child relationships so finally we
use more entering with stackdriver and
that helps us with this 500 you know
streams that we need to babysit and
manage helps us keep track of of those
right we post we have custom time series
that we use that we've designed and we
post our latencies between when event
happened on ebay course ID and when the
record got it certainly the big day
and also the volumes and this is a
snapshot of one of our stock driver
dashboards that shows the volume of the
data so you can see you probably cannot
see the numbers but it has all 500 data
sets here in one place and the top one
shows the number of batches and these
lines that are kind of on the top it's
it's about 20,000 every every five
minutes so it's a lot so it helps us we
have a large set of this monitoring so
in case if things are not moving fast
enough we get alerted and we can get in
and add notes to BigTable or fix things
with that I pass it back to misha for
some closing notes so I'd like to thank
you very much Leon and we have the folks
from eBay the team that worked on this
and also we have some folks from the
BigTable team so thank you very much
everyone for contributing to this
project
[Music]
[Music]